hello everyone and welcome to
part two of our series tips and tricks
to better histology
and tissue based research a review of
key factors
influencing the quality of sections and
stains i'm susie valdez of labyrinths
and i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by
leica biosystems for more information
about our sponsor please visit their
site
at leica biosystems.com so let's get
started
i want to remind everyone that this
event is interactive and we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question
box and click send if you have any
trouble seeing
or hearing this presentation just click
on that support tab found at the top
right of your presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to welcome back our presenter
now fiona tarbet
a product manager at leica biosystems in
melbourne
australia for a complete biography of
our presenter
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
fiona welcome again you may now begin
your presentation
okay hi again everyone um i hope you
enjoyed the
last session of tips and tricks to
better histology
so today i'll be taking up where i left
off
and starting with um all of the
workflows
post embedding post tissue processing
with embedding
once again just quick disclaimer these
webinars
are for educational purposes only and
they're not intended
and should not be construed as medical
regulatory or legal advice
so once again just want to set the same
for those who may have missed it but
just to remind everybody of what we're
actually trying to achieve today
so the scene within histology
laboratories whether they be
research or clinical often face the same
sort of problems
that we are in a really high pressure
environment we
need to try and get tissues out in a
shorter turnaround time to get results
which can sometimes lead to more problem
blocks
we often don't have enough time to
actually think problems through
or we don't get told about problems
until
at some time later once everything is
packed away
so there's often pressure for quick
fixes we may not have really experienced
staff or
time to fully train staff and it can be
difficult to have a conversation about
what is actually a problem
when the people that are assessing the
science may not actually be aware of
some of the issues
that labs face
issues with resources technological
change
it can often be a real challenge
so the absolute aim is to produce high
quality seductions and stains in a
minimum time
from blocks that cut easily in a stable
unprolonged storage
with accurate identification and
labeling with associated complete
patient information in minimum time and
consistently
every single day so this presentation is
going to guide you some
through some of the key factors to
achieve great quality
from bedding through to staining
so we start with embedding and this is
sometimes overlooked as a cause of
sectioning difficulties
some of the problems are very obvious if
there's a large
bubble in the wax or the tissue is not
flat
therefore you don't achieve a full face
there's not enough
wax around if somebody has selected the
wrong mould by the time you get to
cutting
but the effect of careless embedding can
be very subtle
and it can make cutting very difficult
so you need to orient the specimen
carefully
in regards to where the microtone blade
is and this is determined at embedding
so
an awareness of how the block will be
placed in the microtome um in your
particular laboratory is really
important for the embedders to know
here's just some examples and just as a
quick
tip always put if you have soft tissues
and harder tissues or mixed blocks such
as in an intestine
make sure your softer elements are
facing the blade
first if you have really hard tissue
like cervix which is quite
dense again make sure that the point of
least resistance meets
blade before the larger tissue does
to make smooth transition through the
block and similarly with skin
you might have a fat an underlying fat
layer
leading up to quite a firm and dense
epidermis
again make sure that the soft tissue
meets the tissue first
before you get into the harder tissues
so distortion during cutting is often
an issue so think of
different causes of excessive
compression when cutting
tissue sections you might think it is
all to do with the
blade but there's actually a number of
different causes here
it could be poor fixation it could be
poor processing
as we talked about in the previous
session the fixation and the processing
has a lot to do
with all of your downstream processes so
always consider
is the block actually the problem or is
the fixation processing a problem
you might have poor quality wax you
might
have a block that's too warm so you need
to make sure that you pull that down
you could be cutting it too fast the
blade could be dull
or the blade is dirty it's this facet
surface is sticky
with wax the blade tilt is too great
fasted angle is too great
so think about some of the causes of
distortion
so distortion occurs during the
sectioning process
the section is compressed on its upper
or outer face
and elongated by the same amount on the
inner face adjacent to the knife
the question is how much of this is
recoverable
the amount of distortion is proportional
to the section thickness
so the thicker the section the greater
the area
affected by distortion you might
consider
reducing the micron thickness of your
of your sections you also need to check
on the facet angle so usually
between 22 and 35
the greater the clearance angle the more
distortion
again usually aim for between four and
nine
degrees and the less resistance to
passage of the section over the facet
surface
the less distortion the nature of the
surface can vary between brands
so when you are thinking about which
blade make sure that you're using the
correct blade for the job
so blades from different manufacturers
will have different specifications
usually you'd select a blade for your
most routine
work a routine might be a blade with an
angle of say 35
degrees um but then other blades might
be
more suitable they might be treated with
special special treatment that is good
for bones or for harder tissues
the other thing that's really important
and is probably again overlooked by
a lot of lab staff is to actually clean
the microtime but learning how to
actually
take apart the knife holder is really
important
there are instructions and like many
many instructions people don't usually
read them
but it is really important to have some
idea or at least even have a nominated
person in the lab who
does know how to correctly maintain the
microphones
there is an image here of microchatter
and again this is often
um attributed to poor processing when in
fact it could just be that it's
called chatter right through the block
because
it's loose blade
so before you cut tissue it needs to be
cold
and that is so you do achieve the
correct thickness
so there's various different methods
different labs prefer they might
put the blocks in a freezer they might
use a cold plate
at four degrees or down to minus five
degrees
varies the surface of melting ice is a
very
common practice or some labs use a cold
spray
there are other methods too if you've
had slightly difficult blocks
to either soak or soften before cutting
and there's a lot of different recipes
either commercial or ones that you can
find and make up yourself and this just
helps with
blocks that are perhaps a little bit too
brittle
or they've still got some calcium in
them or
they're just hard
but just remember the method of your um
of your soaking or softening or just
even
keeping those blocks cold can really
cause changes in morphology
and here's just an example one that we
created ourselves
this is exactly the same block um
the one on the left hand side has been
soaked in water for over 30 minutes
the one on the right didn't have water
so just placed onto a cold plate
and cooled down and you can see the
effect of water seeping into
a block even though clearly the block
was
well processed but it does cause some
distortion to the morphology
again you have a morphological change
you can see it in the block you can see
it in the microscope slide
and it's not due to the tissue
processing it's not due to the fixation
it's just simply that a block has just
been left there a little bit too long
and it's caused issues
some common flotation problems you may
get contamination on your water bath
you may get cross contamination if you
have left two different
sections it could have actually come
from grossing just be aware
it's also quite common people leaving
the tissue
on the water bath at to a high
temperature or for too long which leads
to over over-expansion
again there's morphological change and
differences down the microscope
which have got nothing to do with
how well the tissue was fixed or
processed so just be aware of being
really consistent
making sure that you cut one block at a
time making sure that you
pick up the section in a timely manner
you can see some of the issues that can
happen a bubble from flotation um has
resulted in the detachment of the
section during staining
so where the tissue it wasn't obvious
when you cut the section or dried the
section
there is still a bubble that will cause
and could be a critical part of that
particular tissue that you were looking
at
in downstream staining processes
so just some things to think about
replace water regularly
always skim the surface between blocks
float sections from only one block at a
time
monitor the temperature carefully
usually at about
44 degrees is a good temperature for
water bath
look at what your wax temperature is and
perhaps
10 degrees below the melting point 5 to
10 degrees below the melting point
is appropriate monitor flotation time
carefully
and always assess the section quality
whilst floating out
so some common problems mechanical
damage caused by prodding with forceps
or brush when trying to remove
wrinkles think about some alternative
methods if this is often a problem
you could consider a pre cold water bath
before the
hotter water bath and this can sometimes
be
a control particularly for more delicate
tissues or
perhaps when people are just learning
how to to
cut sections then it is something that
you could consider is
putting the putting the section onto a
cold
water bath dealing with the wrinkles
there and then transferring it onto a
warm water bath ratchet floating out
it's interesting to selecting the best
section
so the first sections which are coming
off from a tool block are often a little
bit thicker
um but they often look like they're
better
because they're a little bit fatter if
you like so the tissue looks better but
it's obvious
it's not usually the best section to
select
so again be consistent with what with
the sections that you are taking off but
consider
the perhaps less you know robust
sections that are
two or three along the ribbon because
they will probably be
your desired thickness
draining and drying sections
very important if they're not drained
properly before drying
some areas may not flatten and that's
because there are water
that's that remain underneath the
section can
that it's actually lifted but it may
look like there is something
um missing in the morphology and you may
not be able to
make some diagnosis at that point
because there's still some water
that's caused this lifting you often do
get inconsistent draining techniques
between
my economists or sometimes in a rush to
get slides into the stainer that they're
just not left
long enough so it is a really important
point to just make sure that there's
standardization through here
but also think of the method of drying i
mean
again seed is often an issue that people
trying to race things through consider
are you using a hot plate is it the
right temperature is it an appropriate
method
for your tissues um does it have hot
spots
and you some tissues are particularly
prone to the heat damage
such as hemophobic tissue
so again some examples here you can see
i see done on the tonsil from the
antibodies cd3
so it wasn't properly flattened and
drained before drying so
resulted in lifting and therefore a
distorted staining pattern
also lifting poor adhesion and folds
have resulted in
almost impossible to diagnose
tissue staining
so moving on to the h knee stain so the
hne stain
is the most common or routine stain in
laboratories throughout the world so
we'll just be going through some of the
theories and some of the issues to look
out for in achieving a really good hne
stain
so achieving consistent high quality is
challenging
there are a lot of quality assurance
programs that can benchmark your stain
and they can be very useful you could
find them online or join the quality
assurance program and participation can
often be a requirement for
laboratory accreditation certainly in a
clinical setting
that would be true so some key
questions
to ask yourself how to resolve some of
the issues around your hd
do you depend on your pathologist or
senior scientist to tell you when
there's something wrong
do you use a suitable control slide do
you look critically at every control
slide
does your staff know how to assess an hd
for quality
at what stages do problems usually arise
and what can you do about them all these
questions can also be applied to
any special stain or to any sea stain
fish stain as well so for an h e
choosing a control slide
is really important it's very important
to have a control slide to monitor
your stain and but you need to therefore
make sure it is robust
so it is a good idea to have a range of
tissues um that demonstrate just
different aspects of
stains they should be cut to your normal
thickness
and if the multi blocks do give you
an opportunity to really do a complete
assessment but
if you do select just one tissue with
your control
make sure that it has got some different
elements there such as gut so you might
have
mucosa um you've got some collagen
you've got some muscle
which all will display some different
staining
patterns and you can really assess how
well your hd
is staining so and
why it's in particularly important to to
select something
[Music]
like a bowel specimen is you might
select something like placenta which is
a notoriously um easy tissue to
stain and often stains really well even
though your
actual stain is not as good as it should
be
so knowing what to look for so there are
some key things that you would be
looking for
so you need to look for some
well-defined nuclear detail
that shows both coarse and fine
hemochromato homochromatin and
nucleoli are looking for mitotic figures
they do stand out very well they should
stand out very well in a good stain
collagen fibers both coarse and fine
should be
well differentiated and a different
differentiation from the smooth muscle
good cytoplasmic texture look at the
luminal margin and look at basement
membranes
nissel granules in autonomic ganglia so
they should be clearly defined
and basophilic um because of the large
amount of
ribosomes so again standing out clearly
in your smooth muscle in between your
smooth muscle
eosinophil granules are strongly stained
cytoplasmic basophilia you can look at
plasma
cells in your laminar propria as well
endothelial cell cytoplasm is well
defined and red blood cells stain
brightly and uniformly
you can create your own scoring hne
scoring matrix
we have created our own scoring matrix
and
this will be delivered to registrants
from this webinar
but basically what uh what we've done is
just look at some different criteria to
look for
for hemotoxin for earson um
and actually where to look and then we
have a three-point scoring system
and just this has just some examples of
um what would be a good what would be a
bad what would be a satisfactory
stain so in this way you can keep a
record
of how well your staining um is going
and how is there any sort of
deterioration you could consider
scoring your controls or you can use
this as
a way of measuring whatever tissue
processing you're looking at
um or whatever your experiment is
actually
trying to achieve
so again think of some different causes
for a weak hematoxylin stain
so we're going to go through some of the
fundamentals of the h e
h for hematoxin and eosin stains
are either regressive or progressive
stains
we're going to be looking at just some
of the areas within the stain
and some of the common problems that you
might find there
so first of all the d-wax it's the very
first step
so if there is residual wax it can cause
staining faults because the stain
cannot access the tissue some of them
might be
very obvious like large areas are not
stained well some might be very
subtle so wax removal is slower when the
slides are cold
and again this is something that if you
cut particularly say control slides or
slides the night before stain them the
next day think about
when you optimized your de-waxing was
that done
on slides that have just been warmed um
sides that have come out of an oven or
slides that have been left cold
either your t-wax is optimized to warm
sides
and cold sides just will not be waxed
correctly
wax removal is slower when sections are
thicker
it's slower with old sections different
solvents
remove wax at different times think
about are you using a
substitute a xylene substitute or xylene
that might take a lot longer if it's
design and substitute
and also when did you last change your
excessive when
did you last change your solvent because
excessive wax will
prevent good dewaxing
so here's um an example and in the
previous
session i talked a little bit about blue
hue and talked about that that can be
caused by
excessive water from under processing or
contamination
here is another example where we might
call
blue hue when it's actually a result of
the wax
still left in tissue and therefore
the stain was not able to penetrate
through
another example here is an unstained
area due to residual wax in a tonsil
with a night sea stain
it's always worth having another cutting
the section again if you do see
some issue as you can see on the left
there are two eosinophilic patches
that do not exist in the same tissue on
the right
and that's purely because there is
residual wax left in the tissue
so moving on to hematoxylin so there are
a number of different
commercial hemotoxins in use or
formulations that you can make up
yourself less common
nowadays but certainly very possible
recipes are freely available
and you can see this is just a chart
that was from
the royal college of pathologists in
australia
where different laboratories
have different preferences for whatever
reason and the marks are
vary and that can be because of the
laboratory or because of
the stains themselves
so some stains are better for
progressive stains
and others are better for regressive
stains
and again just consider what sort of
stain you are planning to do
a progressive stain is where you
stain up to a point your hemotoxin and
then you stain with eosin
a regressive stain is where you
overstain your hemotoxin
and then remove until you're at the
point where you have
good nuclear staining it is a preference
um there's pros and cons for either a
progressive or regressive
stain but just think about what your
formulation is
and whether it is actually more suitable
for
a progressive or a regressive stain
so some common problems these are two
control slides so
um cut the sections of the same
thickness
uh they were stained on an order stainer
using identical
protocols but there's a gap of one week
between the staining of the two sites
and this is where your scoring can come
into it but a quick glance can show you
that there's very big difference
because the stains have gone off over
the week
so hematoxin um needs to be oxidized
into hematin if it's over oxidized
then it becomes a color um
you know over oxidation i went too slow
so if it's over oxidized it can actually
turn
into a colorless product that can't then
be combined with your um mordant
for staining so again if a
hemotoxin is left too long and if it's a
commercial one they will be ripened to a
certain
level but there's still oxidation that
occurs while
the hematoxin is in either standing
instrument or a series of baths
so just remember that if that is left
too long it will
over oxidize and become non-usable
so mentioned earlier there um the
hematin needs to be combined with a
mordant
and this is this combines to a dye lake
the most general aluminium is for its
blue but you may have an iron mordant
which is
particularly useful for special stains
um you might think of
a trichrome when there's acids used as a
steps within the stain then an iron
might be
more suitable than an aluminium but
aluminium is the most common
you need to think about the effect of
the ph
on your um on your complex because again
ph will result in the wrong color
see that the hemotoxin will be
progressively diluted by water carry
over
depending on your water this will alter
the ph
and that so not only dilute the actual
hemotoxin
but it will alter the ph and may result
in poor staining
it is progressively oxidized in the
staining bath
and the oxidation products do not con
contribute to staining
so the effect of staining will depend on
the amount of unoxidized hematoxin in
the solution
which can be progressively oxidized as
the stain
is used most commercial
hne or hematoxin do have stabilizing
agents to slow that oxidation the other
thing to consider
is nowadays most people most labs
use automated stainers so whatever the
recommendation from the manufacturer on
the
either stainer or from the hematoxin
itself
think about what they recommend in terms
of times of protocols because
the design of the of the stainer
the size of the surface area that is
available for oxidation
of the reagent will contribute to how
long that hemotoxin will last
on the instrument
this is the same for the surface area of
the standing bath if it's a staining
bath on the bench
as much as with a main a staining
instrument
think about where the hemotoxin is
stored
the ph of alum haemotoxin is important
as we went through and it is adjusted to
favor the staining of the nuclei so
again the progressive will have a
you would add a slight amount of acid
in order slightly more acidic for a
progressive stain
and that is to make it more make the
stain more selective
for the nuclei
um as an example citric acid is added to
the maya's hemotoxin
to drop the ph and it's a feature of
progressive staining
moving on to the differentiation
so differentiation occurs in um
in a regressive stand where you need to
be taking out
that excessive amount of hemotoxin and
just leaving
the elements you do understand with
hemotoxin the nuclei
um well stained so
the variable aster differentiation can
affect the consistency
and again because there's carryover in
either a bench or in an instrument you
will
find that they become progressively
diluted and so the optimal
differentiation times can change
and this is particularly an issue if you
have a quite an aggressive
time um so with acid elk with
hydrochloric acid that is fast
you need to be considering you know how
how your protocol has been optimized
so you can dilute the differentiated
times
um the differentiator time so that times
can be lengthened
and add a bit more control and
consistency
or you can use what is commonly called
as a clarifier rather than a
differentiator
and this is using a different acid
usually acetic acid
or some weak acid so that it actually
gives you
more time and more control you do need
to blue
after use of any acid alcohol
so the water wash
so the bluing can happen in
tap water if the tap water happens to be
quite alkaline
so just be aware of what the ph of your
tap water is because it can
vary quite a lot this is a particularly
important in all steps if you're staying
if you're using tap water
changing the ph in any step can have an
effect
so you could use scott's tap water
substitute again either commercial or
make up your own ammonium water is
commonly used
um and this is just purely to to blue
the nuclei particularly after as
after both progressive and regressive
hemitoxin
so eosin again the ph of eosin is
very important whether you use an
aqueous eosin
or an alcoholic acid so generally around
ph4 is is good
so if the ph rises the staining becomes
weaker and the easen will therefore even
though it appears to be his staining
um it will wash out during the
post-eastern rinses
residual alkali from bluing or from your
tap water
can cause weak and patchy staining be
aware
you can add several drops of acetic acid
to eosin and that does
improve the staining and this might give
a little more life to your
eosin if it's dropping off too quickly
because of carryover
however eastern needs
does display differential standing and
that's what you want that is desirable
and achievable if you do have two acid
um an esn if you've added too much you
will get
stronger staining but you lose the
ability of esm to actually differentiate
in
in the different elements that it needs
to
so clearing must make sure that there is
no
water left before you apply a cup slip
so clearing
really needs to be you need to make sure
that those solutions are
changed and often
so the final change about suit alcohol
must be uncontaminated
there must be sufficient changes of
alcohol and sufficient time to complete
dehydration and any water will prevent
cyan penetrating and thus the section
will not clear
also remember your laboratory
environment
are you using xylene substitutes because
styling substitutes will
take on more water any alcohol will
absorb water from the environment so
just make sure that you
are aware of the humidity in your
laboratory but
storage conditions of alcohols and make
sure that you change at an appropriate
time
so cover slipping absolute clarity with
maximum resolution is required
the slide coverstip and mountain must
all have the same refractive index
and this minimizes refraction at glass
mountain section
interfaces water must be completely
removed
the clearing agent must be compatible
with mountain
just check if you have got a new
mountain
or you are thinking about a different
clearing agent other than
xylene that you sometimes will have an
incompatibility there
make sure that your mountain is free of
any crystalline structures make sure
it's within its use by date
another thing that um people commonly
are very confused about is seeing the
appearance of
dark nuclei that appear to be for no
good reason
and this is sometimes we call it corn
flaking
when the there's actually air that's
over the nuclei
and it's because the section has been
allowed to dry out
and this could be in a commercial cover
slipper or
in a um just in your staining
in your bench staining but just be aware
if the slides do start to dry out
you might get these tiny little dark
areas
over the nuclei and it's actually air so
we cover slip
so some key points
and this is from the previous webinar to
this webinar
it's really important to think globally
to improve the quality
so you need to think of all of the
different causes from both
management level which could be staff
and training or
fatigue all of those kind of management
level
issues as well as the myriad bench level
issues that need to be considered
i really encourage if we can do a better
attitude
be systematic in your approach to
quality improvement so tackle one thing
at a time
and take it through to completion but
really give some thought as to
where problems could be and what is
consistent
every step taken at the bench has an
impact on quality
so all the staff must know
so optimizing fixation processing are
essential first steps in improving
quality
but as we've been through in today's
session
you can see that there are other things
that
appear to mimic problems with fixation
or problems with tissue processing
that are actually um caused by some very
minor things
such as leaving a block in water for too
long
perhaps somebody's gone to tea and left
some blocks soaking
um thinking about your balance of your
hemotoxin
and ears and thinking about
is your protocol for staining optimized
um
on a cold slide or a warm slide so just
these little things can make such an
enormous difference to your
um your quality within the lab so
that's my last slide
questions
thank you fiona for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you want to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
get started
we already have some great questions
coming in from our audience members
fiona our first question is my rooted
tissue is
dry and powdery after processing
we use a 12-hour protocol what do you
suggest for that
okay so the first thing um
rodent tissue is dry and brittle
sometimes
12 hours is a very long protocol for the
size of tissue
and this is particularly
i would recommend optimizing that tissue
protocol
many tissue processes nowadays are very
efficient
compared to some of the older dip and
dunk
with no heat no vacuum no agitation
so i think the first thing would be to
optimize that tissue processing
protocol to pull it back
quite a bit the other thing too is if it
is giant powdery
just using at sectioning some cold water
on your block will actually help you get
a section
so yeah just try and sort of soften up
that tissue so that you can recover it
but
the best advice is optimize your tissue
processing protocol
thank you so much our next question how
do you suggest
we fix bone tissue
interesting question so there's a lot of
different types of
bone specimens so um and i talked about
in the webinar
um for the first webinar it's really
about preparation
of your specimen so bone needs to be
very well
fixed particularly if you're going to be
decalcifying
to really protect it from the effects of
decalcification
so if it's a large piece of bone think
about
using a very fine saw to to sort
just so that you expose the bone to a
good fixative
think about increasing the length of
time that you would
normally for a tissue a soft tissue
just to make sure that there is time to
penetrate
you could think about using an
alternative fixative such as davidson's
which is more
an acetic acid alcohol formula mixture
but again the caution with any
alternative
fixatives is look at what the
recommendations are
if you're making out up yourself or if
there's a manufacturer for an
alternative
they will recommend the time of fixation
and
in the case of a davidson's don't leave
it there for more than 24 hours before
you then
re-put it into a neutral bucket formula
or an alternative fixative
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
our next question comes from someone who
needs some advice about their study
i'll share the study first and then give
you the question i'm studying the
endocrine disruptor compounds related
histopathological alteration in fish
gonads
and following the oecd guidelines are
related to the same
the oecd guidelines mention the fixation
of gonads
in davidson for 24 to 48 hours
and then subsequent washing and storage
in 70
ethanol however i will be in the field
for two months and there will be a gap
of three months before i actually start
the tissue processing
histopathological examination so kindly
could you guide and share your opinion
if the storage of
samples in ethanol for such long periods
will have any effect in histology
examination at cellular level
and what are the temperature conditions
that should be maintained
during preservation time and thank you
in advance
for your guidance
well so it's a great question
um i think first of all if you're
following guidelines and if you're
needing to do a particular study
protocol
then follow the guidelines um
again i mean it's interesting the
davidson's is as i said with
many other of those kind of fixatives
they do have a limited
time in which you should store your
tissues
putting it into 70 and that is an older
technique which i think some people
still do is
to put it into 70 if they need to do ihc
um after the initial fixation and this
is because
um you know the first part of fixation
with neutral buffered formula
is reversible the second as it gets
stored longer and longer and more and
more chemical reactions and cross links
occur
it becomes irreversible so depending on
what
downstream process you want to do you
really need to think about the storage
in terms of temperature um again it's
it's really if it's 70
is it going to start evaporate what will
preferentially evaporate
you want to make sure that it doesn't
evaporate so
it's more water you might want to make
sure that it is
in a fixative so
yeah my advice there is follow the
guidelines
consider what your downstream processes
are in this case it's very specific
don't be afraid of 70 but do
make sure that you are in an airtight
container
or not in heated conditions
but yeah follow the guidelines i suppose
is really
ask specifically what your study
protocol requires
thank you so much fiona and we have time
for one more question
this audience member says there are a
lot of questions about
specific protocols can you give me some
general recommendations
about protocols
yeah i mean it is um so
certainly in the previous presentation i
shared a theoretical
theory of different of protocols and
where smaller tissues
might require shorter protocol
very large tissues might require much
longer and it's sometimes
difficult to balance that when you have
a mixed workload
particularly if you're looking at
research in more animal tissues this can
be even
more varied than looking at human
tissues
so i guess if you have a particular type
of tissue it is working towards
optimizing
within your laboratory within the
reagents that you are
looking at using some guidelines in
terms of your
ratio of alcohol to xylene and wax which
should be about a 1.5 to two to one to
one
ratio is it is a good guidance
um so yeah i think
the protocols themselves really have to
be think about
have you got one sort of specimen that
you're processing
have you got a mixture of different
specimens have you got the luxury to
separate out the specimens um to
different times of different retorts
and then think about what is best for
that
tissue what is best for the laboratory
too in terms of xylene substitutes to
xylene
um very important in terms of you know
how exposed staff is so i guess it was a
general questions and general general
answers
on it but effectively make sure you
validate
make sure you optimize particularly for
what you want to do
and think about the ratios of your
reagents
and think about the times if you're
using things like xylene substitutes
which you will need longer times hope
that helps
thank you so much fiona and i want to
thank you for your presentation today
would you like to provide any final
comments for our audience before we
close
um yes if um as a last slide i'd just
like to
show the audience okay there are a
number
of references that are available on the
leica buyer systems website
in particular there are two textbooks
which
are available to download as ebooks or
to download and keep in your laboratory
so these were authored by jeffrey rolls
who was a senior lecturer at
rmit in histology and
they're really really excellent books so
101 steps goes through
just very basic tips some of which i
have covered
here today and difficult blocks and
reprocessing
will talk you through some of the
methods of reprocessing
it's there is often
there's quite a few decision trees that
you need to go through um
we shared some where if it's over
processed reprocessing may not help but
then what do i do
if it's under processed what do i do and
that can be very
specific to what's actually happened is
it underprocessed was it too large was
it
the wrong proportion so have a look at
these books and any other educational
material
it can really help just to get some of
these decision trees
think about what the next steps are but
also 101 steps is
hints and tips so thank you
thank you all thank you all for
listening
and thank you again fiona for your time
today and for your important research
before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
and questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed
by our speaker via the contact
information you provided
today at the time of registration and we
once again
want to thank you all and we want to
thank our lab roots
and our sponsor leica biosystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
you can view this webinar on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via an email
when it's available for replay
that's all for now until next time
everyone take care be safe
stay healthy bye thank you